to everyone subject an email about email
it seems like everything these days
generates email every treaty every trade
negotiation every real-estate
transaction and pretty much every
lobbyist you talk to makes more and more
email and juggling all those emails can
be tough it's a chore to carry around
multiple devices for most people it's
one device for work one device for home
and one device for lazing with
billionaire Arabs that's why we made
Hillary male the all-in-one email
solution for work for yoga class or for
highly classified information your
messages are stored far away on a server
in the garage of a luxury home in rural
New York protected by a ten foot fence
and a state-of-the-art Secret Service
agent named Phil making sure your email
is far from the reach of freedom of
information laws congressional oversight
and journalists and for extra peace of
mind you have the ability to disappear
anything you don't want anyone else to
read regardless of your ethical
obligation opt for convenience opt for
Hillary male Hillary male is not
protected from hacking
you